So here again we have our dynamic trace,
now a bit bigger.
Remember that the input was double quote followed by a less-than sign.
What we get in the end is the output, which is just the less-than sign.
In the dynamic trace, we can now, again, follow back the dependency.
For instance, from out--out is being read here.
Where was it last written?
That's over here, so this depends on this earlier statement.
Here we have out that's being read.
Now in the dynamic trace you can actually follow this whole thing
and see where it was last written, again,
which is up here.
And here we have the character c, which stems from the second iteration of the for loop.
And this relates to s, which depends on the input.
So, again, we have a chain of dependencies: out going up here,
up here, up here, up here,
and you can also see this as a cause-effect chain.
S had this value; therefore, c became a less-than sign,
which was edited out, which finally resulted in the input also having a less-than sign.
Again, we can use these dependencies to build a slice.
However, now the slice would be a dynamic slice
because it is built on the dynamic trace.
Starting with the assert statement,
we see that out=out+c is being executed,
and therefore part of our slice.
We see that the initialization of out is part of our slice
We see that the for loop is part of our slice.
And, of course, when we call "remove HTML markup"
where s is being set, this also becomes part of our dynamic slice.
So far we only looked at dynamic data dependencies,
but of course there are also dynamic control dependencies.
Every condition that gets evaluated, that is, executed and controlled
whether a statement in question is executed or not,
builds a dynamic-control dependency.
Therefore, since we executed out=out+c,
the controlling conditions are also part of the dynamic slice.
>From these conditions, we again get more dynamic data dependencies,
which you can look up, again, in our dynamic trace.
For instance, here the tag variable, which is being read over here,
was last set up here.
Therefore, this condition is data-dependent on this initialization.
So here's a quiz.
Which other statements in the program are also part of the dynamic slice?
Is it quote=false?
Is it tag=true?
Is it tag=false?
Or is it quote=not quote?